so good morning thank you for being here
sorry I'm late this week I have my two
sons our two sons visiting here in Palm
Springs because you know as my wife's
milestone birthday bond marks the first
and the boys couldn't be here for
various reasons and so they decided they
would come so we're having a lot of fun
course you have a great big late
breakfast and everyone's cooking up
something different and sitting there
and chatting and also I like the
scramble off here to have my session but
I want to talk today about confidence
because again I always I think about
what to talk about here as we're
proceeding in our 90 day challenge we're
trying to achieve a breakthrough and of
course there's a lot of pressure to to
stay with the you know the commitment so
I committed to to try to make a
breakthrough in both Persian and Arabic
and of course you know with with the
kids visiting I don't have much time to
study either Arabic or Farsi Persian and
so the question is you know how much are
you going to lose or how do you find the
time and is this gonna affect you know
my you know success and stuff like that
and and I began so so anyway I have to
jump in the car because we have no more
milk and eggs so I jump in the car to go
to the store I put on my Arabic had been
a boy herd for a couple of it from it
for a couple of days and and I listen to
it and I understand in some ways more I
hear things that didn't hear before and
somehow I have this confidence that I
will eventually there is no question in
my mind that I will learn Arabic however
long it takes so it doesn't matter
obviously not everyone is in that
position some people are in a hurry to
learn the language because they need it
for work but you know there is no end
point in learning languages even if you
speak English well and you use it for
work you can always in
you
can you write there phone huh boy I mean
that's awful that they would suddenly
interrupt our connection and asked me to
confirm my password but it's just
terrible you know I realized here I
don't know what they're I'm still
kidding people here there he is oh
you're back okay I'm back yeah so that's
pretty bad they just cut you off in the
middle of your Google hangout and ask
you to confirm your password
unbelievable
no is it is it stuff okay so I have this
confidence I'm assuming everything is
okay right now why don't we see yeah
oh yeah you're bad there he is okay so
you know I have this confidence that I
will eventually speak Arabic I will let
eventually as I listened to my aljazeera
podcast and don't understand more than
20% although I pick up phrases here and
there I'm confident that I will learn I
just have to stay with it so there is no
end point so yeah that's what I was
saying so if you're working and you're
using a language whatever it might be
your work you can always improve so
there is no end point and I I just know
that if I put it in the time I will
eventually get better and better and
better I have that confidence there is
no way I will not learn this language
the same is true with my version so I
thought spoken in or not any or listen
to any Persian and then I had a lot I
had committed to with my tutor at link
once a week that we chat so I show up
and actually I didn't do so badly didn't
do so badly I was looking for words but
I was communicating and so here again I
know that if I continue in fact I'm
looking forward to spending more and
more time with Persian and with Arabic
but maybe over the next coming years
because as I said I'm going to Ukraine
in May and so I want to work on
improving my Slavic languages and then
I'm going to Japan in the fall
also I want to work on my Korean Arabic
and Persian aren't going anywhere as
languages whatever I put into them is I
still have it I have the the lessons
that I have studied and there will be
more material that I can use so I am
confident in fact I'm looking forward to
enjoying all of these languages I'm
confident that I will get there I'm
confident that it's something I want to
do like sometimes we're in this
situation like why am i learning this
language why am I not doing something
else so that this is and it's so easy to
be distracted today you know and you
have to believe you have to be confident
that this is something worth doing and
the course I do I doing it and I'm
confident that I will get there I am
confident as well that this approach
listening and reading with the
occasional review of words the
occasional review of grammar essentially
what we do at Linc and I enjoy the
environment at Linc other people might
have other environments they enjoy but
I'm confident that will it will take me
to success so the confidence that I
think about is never confidence that I
will speak well because it doesn't
matter however while I speak is is well
enough I'm never in a situation where
I'm worried about how I will do because
however while I do that's all I can I
can't really control it and yet so even
when I spoke with my person tutor I
struggled but still three months ago I
couldn't say anything in person so now
we can have tea have a bit of a
conversation and so that's good it
doesn't bother me that I was struggling
to find words so the confidence to me
the importance the important confidence
is the confidence that it's worth doing
worth learning the language you will
eventually achieve success the method
that you're using is is is the one you
want to be using so you're confident
about what you are doing and to me
that's the most important it's like
saying link we measure people's level of
activity to what extent are people
engaged with the language listening
reading how many worth thread how many
links created how many
words that have become known this is
more than anything an indication of your
level of activity if you put the
activity in you will improve so you know
it's enough to be confident that you're
doing something that's worthwhile that
is going to work for you that you can
achieve success you stay active with the
language and the results will look out
for themselves some people may be better
at retaining vocabularies some people
may be better at pronunciation it
doesn't really matter it's it's it's the
commitment to what you're doing the
confidence that is worth doing and then
it's gonna lead you to success and
therefore you stay active you stay
engaged with the language to me that's
important and after that the results
will look after themselves so that's
what I wanted to say about confidence
and and and similarly so if I go a few
days now where I can't give up my
language learning because I have my kids
visiting and we're doing a bunch of
stuff together yeah that happens and
it's gonna happen I'm sure to many of
you in your 90 day challenge there will
be a couple of days when you can't stay
with the program doesn't matter when you
get back to it you'll pick it up very
quickly you won't lose you won't slip
very much as long as you're committing
for the bulk of the 90 day period to
really go at it to achieve a
breakthrough so that's all I wanted to
say and I'm curious to see what sorts of
questions we have all right we are going
to go Bing Bing Bing Bing go to the top
here bla bla Salam alaikum have all blah
blah I love your work thank you oh boy
yeah Shekhar's is Ilan
da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da okay but sister
how many words of reading per day to you
and suggest um I mean we do have some
targets at link I must say that um I use
the the sort of words of reading and the
links and stuff like that more as a wrap
what I have done to confirm to myself
that I am being active and therefore I
will eventually get to my goal
so even when I think I'm not making
progress I look at how many words I read
I look at how many words I now know and
I am confident that that's gonna bring
me to my goal I am improving even though
there are many days where I don't feel
that I'm improving so there are many
days that you lack the confidence that
all your effort is getting you anywhere
and so that's how I look at our
statistics as a record of what I have
done the distance that I have traveled I
don't necessarily set myself a goal of
how many words I want to read that day
because it's a simply do and I feel like
doing if I do more listening some days
or tomorrow reading some days so be it
go crazy go for his 90th you know people
often ask some ask me how many ways how
many language did I speak so very
briefly 10 that I can turn on now with
varying degrees of fluency and 10 that I
would have to warm up before I could
really communicate and so particularly
now the 19th and 20th Arabic and Persian
but I can carry on a very limited
conversation and there are things that I
understand and things that I don't
understand so I'm to varying degrees no
22 varying degrees
I can speak certainly 10 without too
much difficulty and another 10 with much
more difficulty what you suggest some
people are always in a hurry my cousin
has to take some exams okay yeah
obviously if you have to take exams but
the basic methodology in my opinion is
still listening and reading listening
because listening comprehension is key
listening is what you're doing in the
listening and reading is you are
bringing in this sort of structure of a
new language you are bombarding your
brain with a new language experience
because the brain in the case of
Giovanni I presume your cousin is an
Italian is brain structured for the
Italian language the way the Italian
language expresses things is standard
hardwired in his brain that works so now
you come with this other way English or
whatever language now there's
another way of expressing these things
new songs new phrases new structures so
you have to push that you have to start
to give the brain the chance to form
these a separate control center for a
different language and the first foreign
language is the most difficult because
your brain is relatively inflexible
because it's so used to your native
language by the third or fourth or fifth
language - the brain is not more
flexible there are all these different
sounds and different ways of saying
things and so the brain is a little more
receptive but for the first language
it's it's tough
so the it's intensive exposure to the
language now while you are you know
listening a lot and reading a lot
naturally you notice certain things that
seem strange to you in the new language
might be English because we don't say
that in Italian we just say this some
other way so then you may want to look
something up in grammar but I would
advise your cousin Giovanni not to spend
too much time trying to memorise grammar
rules probably that won't be very
helpful won't be able to remember them
what you need to do is get em a civics
poseur so in the case of your cousin
step it up
do you know turn off if it's Italian
that is his mother tongue don't listen
to any Italian don't read any Italian
reading just listen to English you think
you know look at words you gotta if
you're listening and you can't
understand you gotta get out the text
somehow just step it up is all I would
do it I've occasionally refer you know
have a small grammar book that you fit
through it reminds you of a certain
things it does have some benefit but you
can't try to memorize those things okay
here we have the biggest conundrum for
many is is how to speak in a foreign
language as as well as we write yeah
obviously when we are speaking it's more
difficult than one garage because when
we write we have time we have time to
think
but I think when we're learning a
language speaking and writing is more or
less the same in other words we aren't
gonna write some super eloquent academic
prose will probably write much the way
we speak so the two are connected and in
order to speak well and develop the
ability to on the fly come up with the
words that you need you simply have to
speak a lot so you step up your input
step up your listening in reading but
you also have to find opportunity to
speak more so that might mean hiring
online tutors or trying to find people
in your community that you can talk to
the bigger okay how do you find in
Spanish well if give el Spanish again I
don't know what your body of Spanish is
that native language your Spanish is the
language that is being learned here
maybe you can tell me okay
Steve you obviously three keys are
motivating time and noticing how do we
keep motivation motivation comes from
confidence I mean the motivation comes
from within but to maintain that
motivation it's helpful to find
something in the culture of the language
that you're learning that you find
interesting that you're curious about so
you don't have to like all aspects of
the culture but you want to try to find
something so you've got to look for
things of interest whether it be songs
or books or newspaper articles or if you
have a friend in the language you'd have
to find something there that's
attractive I find those kinds of things
are motivate personally I enjoy
discovering a new language
I enjoy discovering how they say things
in Arabic versus Persian versus other
languages okay I've been on virgin for
six months I can't have a conversation
how many lessons have you had in three
months hmm I'd have to look up my I
would have to look up I will tell you
exactly let's just now let me just say
to Bella in the sky I have started
having conversations in Persian much
earlier
have done certainly than I did in for
example check even though I had studied
even though I had studied Russian for
quite a few years and so therefore I had
a lot of vocabulary a sense of the
grammar and check is written in the
Latin alphabet
so therefore check should be much easier
but I started speaking earlier in
Persian and to me the reason is simply
the mini stories so the mini stories a
link are a phenomenal way to build up
your ability to speak because they are
focused on the most common verbs in the
language and there's lots of repetition
and so I would very much recommend that
you use the mini stories now I am going
to share my strength in order to show
you ok screen share and we go here
hopefully this is start screen share and
everyone ok and I guess you can see my
screen here and conversation reports so
I have 26 that's the quick answer 26
conversation reports and just to give
you an example of oh you know what I'll
tell you so it goes back to August 20th
August 20th 21st 30th 6/7 these are all
the conversation reports that I have no
I'm gonna show you something
wait a second here yeah yeah I'm talking
about some on in Ukraine about maybe
having a session there but rather that
it that where are we where did she go oh
I know where I can find her if I go to
my tutors and if I go to my activities
then I have conversation report received
I have not yet opened this conversation
report
and so what do we see here view report
so this is my Arabic God no I don't want
him where Monday the 8th with Rana oh
this is the one sorry view report ok so
this has all the words that I tried to
use in my conversation in Persian she
even has some audio I'm gonna give her 5
stars and I'm gonna import so now I have
a lesson a lesson which Rhonda has also
recorded birthday anyway so I mean I can
talk about the fact that we have my
son's visiting his haram you know done
then all its gonna stop I can have a
simple conversation stop that and we are
now back here so the answer is I have
had 26 conversations mostly in the last
three months and so that's that
greetings again were Tirico regarding
learning Chinese idioms and their usage
what are your thoughts so they become
sort of priority mother I am NOT a big
fan like and when you say idioms I don't
know if you're referring to son shot you
to show you for example the Chun er the
sort of elegant little 4 character
expressions in Chinese which sort of a
sign of some sophistication and and to
some extent all Chinese people or many
Chinese people know a lot of them some
are rarer than others I think you know
there's sort of an adornment on your
Chinese they're not so crucial I think
you need to learn the basic structure of
the language the most frequent verbs say
things that you need to say and at some
point later on you will find that having
heard many of these Cheung you you'll
start using them and people will be very
impressed the Chinese
native speaker Wow and so it's a bit of
a show-off thing I don't think you're
crucial I tried your book on a link and
I noticed your best languages are the
ones you learned first French Spanish
Chinese now wouldn't you like to get one
of the newer ones to that level yeah I
mean the languages I speak the best
other ones that I've spoken the most and
so the order actually isn't French
Spanish Chinese Japanese it's French
Japanese Chinese in specs that's the
order in which I speak them because
that's that's the amount that I spoken
in those languages I have I speak German
fairly or Swedish fairly freely but I
don't have a much larger vocabulary in
Russian than I have in German or Swedish
because I have done so much listening
and reading in Russia for example what I
like to be able to speak Russian as well
as Spanish or Chinese I'd love to but
you know you can only do so much like
it's the conundrum is am I gonna spend I
would love to improve my Japanese
I speak Japanese quite well but I would
love to improve it I have trouble
reading novels in Japanese it's a bunch
of vocabulary that I don't have sure I'd
love to do that I've only got so many
hours in the day so what I love to you
know improve my Russian or who do I want
to learn Persian that's the conundrum
now I'm working on Arabic and Persian
right now but I am going to Ukraine for
four for two weeks and I'm gonna be in
eastern Ukraine so I presume thank you
but also in the beef so I will be
speaking both Russian and Ukrainian and
by being able to speak it more I'll get
better at it but I think you know I
lived in France for three years I lived
in Japan for nine years Chinese you know
I studied it full-time for a year and I
have Chinese friends in Vancouver
Spanish I thought I did a lot of
hitchhiking in spain so yeah I had lots
of opportunity to speak okay Scott says
that I think motivation comes from
curiosity in fun I agree
what exactly is the 90-day challenge
okay the 90-day challenge is what we do
at mink because you know it comes back
this issue of motivation obviously if we
are independent learner
we're learning on our own there are
times when our motivation lags I don't
feel like studying today and then the
next day on the next day and pretty soon
you lose that habit because habit is
important in any activity whether it be
working out in the gym it have it right
so what we do with the 90-day challenge
is we say to all of our members look
let's have a 90 day challenge we're all
gonna make a special effort to study if
possible every day for whatever it is
and that might consist of an hour of
listening which is easy to fit in and a
half hour of reading and reviewing links
whatever it'll vary from person to
person but everyone senses that we are
together in this 90 day challenge and
link can measure if you're active every
day so you want to maintain that streak
and we know from experience that if you
make a special effort during a 90 day
period you are more likely to take you
know another step in the language
doesn't necessarily mean fluency but a
bit of a break through plus you'll
develop some habits so it's basically a
way of getting a group of us linked
members to commit commit to a 90 day
period of extra effort for example I am
putting in more time right now granted
I'm doing two languages and there are
days when I don't feel like doing it but
I say I'm committed to this 90 day
challenge therefore I gotta do something
so that's essentially what the 90 day
challenge is okay in musashi
asks what made you enter the lumber
industry from being a diplomat so I was
at the Canadian embassy in Tokyo I was
there for four years first two years and
I was a what we call a trade
commissioner so my job as a trade
commissioner is to be aware of issues
that affect trade between Canada and in
this case Japan and also to help
Canadian industry penetrate the Japanese
market so for the first two years I was
on agriculture and foods and the second
two years I was involved with the food
with the lumber industry and of course
because I speak or spoke Japanese I got
to know a lot of people in the industry
a lot of people sort of what we call
downstream in other words in Japan you
have this earth traditional trading
company but then you have people you
know the next level in the distribution
chain I got to know a lot of those
people and so there was a Canadian
company based out of Vancouver that
wanted to set up their own office in
Tokyo and since I spoke Japanese and
knew the industry they approached me and
said would you like to work for us and
no longer there for work for the
Canadian government and I said yes and
so then I stayed on in Japan for another
three years the reason I left the
diplomatic service is that I found it
not so satisfying
you work for government you produce a
bunch of reports or I'm helping other
people maybe you know I help a business
this man make connections to Japanese
counterpart and then he doesn't follow
up and so that all amounts to nothing
and it wasn't all that satisfied whereas
working for a company we had specific
goals we wanted to achieve it was more
measurable it was fun so I made a movie
I have a question do you have any
strategies on approaching new writing
systems it's really hard for me to read
Japanese fluency fluently I still have
to translate in my head greetings from
Chile you know the first of all if it's
the Japanese writing system of course
there's the cannot yet I gotta cut that
cut and then there's the country the
Chinese characters hiragana katakana
is not difficult there's 50 symbols
there syllables
kaku kaku and there is sort of parallel
hiragana for most of the words and
katakana for loan words or words that
sound you know like crash or whatever I
mean there is just a matter of learning
the symbols which is not a lot of work
and then the more you read the better
you get you just have to get used to
them it's like learning Arabic or or
Cyrillic is it's you learn the symbols
and then at first it seems impossible
and then you start reading more and more
and you continue to make the same
mistakes and you do you think it's or
you see a word and you don't to certain
conclusions that you think is this and
it's something else
and just
gradual gradual process the more you
read the better you get with the kanji
with the Chinese characters that's the
same is true that you have to just the
more you read the better you get but you
have to make a special effort to learn
the kanji and I have a system there are
many systems out there you gotta find
something they put in the effort every
day half an hour an hour to learn the
kanji that's with Chinese and with
Japanese that's an additional task that
you have together and once you do that
then there's no reading the more you
read the more you read the better you
get and I like it if you can listen and
then read then you have a bit of
momentum in your reading okay what do
you think about shadowing and please
advise how to use it right away my new
Language Center in Kazakhstan
yes Janos first of all I can expand like
I am gonna learn Turkish and I'm very
curious to know to what extent Kazakh is
different from Turkish but that's in the
future shadowing now shadowing is
something that I don't do there is a man
called professor argh Elias a are gue ll
es if you look up shadow you'll probably
find him I think he is sort of the
expert on shadow my understanding of
shadowing is that you listen to
something and as you listen to it you
repeat it as you listen to it you repeat
and so it's helping you get the flavor
the intonation of the language I find
that I've tried doing it I find it
difficult to continue doing it most of
my listening is while cleaning up in the
kitchen driving and stuff like that and
I just listen and I listen with the goal
of then reading in order to figure out
what the meaning was I think it is
important to get the intonation of the
language we can do it by shadowing we
can also do it without chattering so we
could lay say have a paragraph in front
of us or a sentence listen to it and
then read it trying to imitate the
intonation or we can sporadically as
we're listening to something and I do
this sporadically I hear something and I
repeat it so I
the shadowing just means that but I
could be wrong and therefore I suggest
you google and in particular I think
Professor Alexander or agalya's is the
expert on shadowing good luck with your
Language Centre in Kazakhstan make your
visit Monday is translating and
uploading content for new dean for a new
language a volunteer service or do
contributors receive some kind of
payment
first of all any Content that's uploaded
has to be free of copyright this is from
Aaron has to be free of copyright if we
find anything that's not free of
copyright we have to remove it but many
people have spoken to their spouse
friends whatever talked about different
things or recorded stuff about history
or there's a whole range of things and
we would love to get more of it there is
a very small level of I don't you know
what I think there's there is some
compensation we used to have a system
where we would compensate points of
people that didn't use them within a
three-month period as a means of
generating some revenue for people who
provided us with content not everybody
liked that system so we decided to
discontinue it I don't know the
immediate answer but it's not a lot most
people who upload content do it in a
spirit of helping others it can be for
example a language school that puts up
some content and then huh as a link to
their language school so they're
promoting they're putting up five ten
lessons in order to attract people to
their language school or some other
language system different reasons why
people upload ah but I don't think the
revenue from it although there are
people who are who have put up so much
content in Russian for example or German
but they do get several hundred dollars
a month from this content it's described
somewhere in the site maybe if you were
to send an email to Eric at link
Atlantic you calm he could give you more
detailed a more detailed explains
don't really know much more than that
did you have other jobs than diplomacy
before retirement from Vincent well I
left the Diplomatic Service after seven
years I worked for two different lumber
exporting companies based in Vancouver
in other words the companies were based
in Vancouver I was in Tokyo then I went
back to Vancouver and worked for this
company in Vancouver and then I set up
my own lumber company in 1987 basically
taking advantage of my knowledge of the
products that were needed in Japan my
knowledge of the contacts that I had in
Japan and I still have that company and
that has been my major activity has been
my involvement with the lumber industry
okay hey Kirk just as a hug yet a slower
I carry that she does okay
Zef a geek again I'm gonna work on my
Russian when I get there Ukraine I don't
and so it's different is how often do
you go to a dictionary when you read it
if I don't if I am NOT if I'm not
reading online I don't use a dictionary
if I if I you know I can leave five ten
percent of the words if I'm reading in
Polish and I don't know the word that is
leave I'm not gonna bother looking it up
in the dictionary it's too
time-consuming and I forget right away
if I'm reading on link every word that I
don't know I look it up if I'm not sure
I look it up and and when I'm reading on
link I have blue words that I have never
seen before that I might look up I have
yellow words that I have seen before and
how are you forgotten and so I will also
look at them but how many that amounts
to it depends on how many new words
there are in the text I hope that
answers your question okay I'm a huge
fan your Diner crush jared is it normal
to feel discouraged when you don't
perceive progression the normal ought to
hear everything you hear
oh yeah it is normal to be discouraged
because we feel we aren't making as much
progress as we would like that is
absolutely normal there
times when I say geez you know I've been
at this Arabic and I still can't
understand us
still can't say what I want to say so
that's very very common that's where I
think our we need to remember like if I
in Arabic Aziz I can't understand but
then I look at if I bring in a new
article from al-jazeera there's lots of
new words but there's also a lot of
words that I know so I may think I'm not
making progress but I'm making progress
and I had a conversation with the the
tutor whose name of showed up I remember
the lassies or something and he agreed I
have improved a lot I'm speaking a lot
better so generally we are progressing
faster than we think but not as fast as
we would like we have unrealistic
expectations and it is also normal not
to understand everything we listen to
listening comprehension is the most
important skill because you know if I
feel uncomfortable engaging with a
native speaker it's not because I can't
say what I want to say it's because I
can't understand what they're saying and
so that's why link is based on the idea
that you need to do a lot of listening
and then reviewing what you've listened
to because you want to build up that
listening comprehension but yes it's
perfectly normal not to understand
especially say movies television
programs all of that kind of stuff or if
you're in a conversation with three or
four other speakers they're not
necessarily directly talking to you it's
more difficult Oh Rebecca here when you
have lesson with your tutor do you have
a set topic to discuss or do you simply
chat about your daily activities we have
no set topic the good tutors are able to
bring you up so you know Ronna in person
did always starts with you know chicka
ba ba nice you know what's new nothing
much and then okay so then I said you
know we had this a lot as I know you
know my wife had a birthday party and we
talked about
my son's came to visit and stuff and
then she'll start talking about other
subjects he might ask me about what
motivates me to learn languages we might
talk about well had another person tutor
he said are we always talking we have
been talking about politics and she says
now let's talk a little bit about daily
like what do you like to eat in other
words I think it's up to the juror to
keep the conversation going the learner
is already under a certain amount of
pressure trying to speak the language so
the tutor comes up with subjects and the
tutor the good tutors are very patient
when you're struggling they don't
quickly give you the English they let
you struggle they say it in different
words and the hour goes by very quickly
but we don't have predetermined when I
started in Persian and Arabic when I
couldn't say anything and when I was
having so much trouble reading we would
read online like I would share my screen
and I would read and then we would
discuss say the mini story that I had
read this was particularly useful in
Persian because we don't have text to
speech for Persian we only have text to
speech for Arabic but even from our
Arabic that text to speech is not very
reliable so to get me going in the early
stages I did a fair amount of reading
online but now I'm progressed to the
point where I no longer wanna do that I
just want to talk okay I am a native
Persian speaker and I am learning German
for about a month my level in English -
something wrong B - is it better for me
to learn German from English sources or
Persian sources I would do both because
there's obviously a lot more English
sources than Persian sources I'm
assuming I just don't know but I'm
assuming coz but I would use a bit of
both but I would certainly use English
no harm done and it would make you you
can then access more material I set my
dictionary language here to English but
I have this two sort of other languages
that I use are Russian and Korean simply
to kind of see what the translation is
in those other languages hey Steve how
did
practice writing in Chinese by hand in
context I kept a diary for a few months
buzz looking for suggestions oh yeah I
mean I was taking a course the
government was paying for me to learn
Chinese we had the right we were given
questions we had to write we have
assignments we had to translate so I
didn't you know he wasn't like I think
would be difficult like I find this
diary stuff that's very difficult to
maintain something like that if you're
given an assignment translate this into
that you do it well nothing prevents you
from translating stuff as well family
doing today fine
Jorge extent it's good to have a
language tutor I think language tutors
are good language tutors are good they
are a source of motivation guidance you
want to do well for your tutor you want
to improve and they're a source of
content because after every discussion
with my tutor I get a detailed report of
all the words and phrases that I
struggle to use and very often they
record it for me so it becomes a
language it becomes a lesson and then I
can review them going back six months
remembering our conversations and
reviewing the words that I struggle to
use so I think language tutors are great
you don't have to do it every day twice
a week is fine okay I studied it for two
years
yesterday I started studying link and I
have five thousand words I'm probably on
no more than fifteen thousand words
should I start to practice to speak yeah
it's always a good time I would say you
get get a tutor at link and start once a
week and then if you want increase it to
twice a week because speaking is
important like let's not you know I
emphasize input based learning to build
up your potential in the language build
up your vocabulary your comprehension
your sense of the language your
familiarity with the structure but
eventually you got to speak and in order
to activate that you have to speak a lot
so I would start speaking like with
Persian I started speaking quite early
the same with Greek I'm starting to
speak much earlier now because I have
the mini
stories that give me some momentum oh my
how many hours have you put into farce
in the past three months okay I will
again share my screen for a sec here and
start screen share and I will give you
an answer so if I go here and this is
something that you can all do here so go
to your profile and in the last three
months if I look at for example
listening so I have listened 60 hours
but my daily is declining somewhat
because of course doing it in
combination with Arabic so if I looked
at my Arabic here and if I go to my
profile and if I look at my last three
months and if I look at my listening so
I've been listening to more Farsi so 42
hours but it has picked up a little bit
recently so yeah I mean I'm doing two
languages and combined is about a
hundred hours over the last three months
if I look at let's see let's get back to
Farsi because that's what you were
asking Persian if I look at my here
profile if I go again to the last three
months and if I look so this is the
known words total but if I look at links
created which is another activity again
I guess I'm doing less but
still it's 3,700 I mean it difficult to
say hey how much time do I put in I
think I put in you know I put in two
hours a day so three and a half days of
Arabic three and a half days Persian
most of that is listening and maybe say
an hour plus is listening and another
hour or so is reading and reviewing link
my teeth has been emphasizing learning
the script yeah I would agree with her
first of all let me tell you Bella and
the sky that person is a lot easier than
Arabic song that is also I don't just
use link I also bought some books I
bought I'm sure we turn up coke go maybe
and living language because I think it's
nice to study the same stuff in two or
three different ways but it is I think
you are in this great big problem with a
lot of books is the script is so small
Arabic Farsi the same they give you
these books where it's so small it's for
a new script difficult script it's
impossible too small so I really enjoy
reading on link because I can make the
font as large as I want one thing that's
very useful I know you firstly we can't
do that in person because we don't have
text-to-speech but for Arabic I would
use my dictation function in my
flashcards and then type in Arabic I
hear the thing in text-to-speech and
type and so you're kind of getting
because it takes a while they're used to
those the Arabic script which is what is
used in Persian it was so difficult you
know there's four different forms
depending on whether it's at the
beginning the middle at the end and
standalone and I thought I'd never learn
this script but it's like everything
else in language learning that at first
seems so difficult we eventually get
used if the brain gets used to it
but I think if you're gonna learn Farsi
and you're gonna be able to you're gonna
want to access reading material you're
gonna if you walk by a a grocery store
you want to be able to read what's
written there it's part of learning the
language
I would definitely emphasize reading but
do this do the many stories that link
there is simple stories the translation
in English is available the audio is
available listen to them over and over
again you listen to them often enough
when I started on my version many
stories which is where essentially
started in the language like it seemed
to me impossible first of all there's no
text-to-speech compared to Arabic it's
much more difficult and now they're just
like but I listened to them 30 40 times
so yeah I would get with it
doctor how okay now thank you for your
content yourself stephen krashen
inspired me and now that i better
comfort good to my Japanese studies my
results in skyrocketed
thank you re 3 irth I mean
comprehensible input just works the
grammar explanations the hankie there's
a lot of stuff on the fringes that can
help are we never quite sure how much is
helping but the comprehensible input
works and it's more interesting takes a
little while to get some traction where
you can actually start to comprehend but
it works well link looks thanks for
answering my questions I need to do
these mini stories es Bella you need to
get on the many stories I can show you
my statistics spell of how often I have
listened to them in fact you know what
I'll just take a second here to do that
let's just go here and starts free share
and present everyone so one of the
really useful things let's go to my
lessons here and you know what I always
study on my iPad and I here we are so I
I'm used to do it this is the other
thing you know any lesson that you study
you want to add it to your playlist
because the playlist is across all
platforms so I have my playlist on my
iPhone I have my playlist on my
I have my playlist on I have a nano or
an iPod Touch driver no I have removed
we can only keep a hundred items in our
playlist which is a an item of some
discussion that we're trying to improve
that
so if I've heard story 16 16 times I can
assure you that story one I've heard it
40 it's just that after a while you
don't need to listen as often same
material but you know 18 times 9 times
as you can see this tells you how many
times I've listened to these various
stories and getting towards them the
recent ones but here for keys Navarro no
I listen to my you know recording our
lesson 5 times and that he is man you
know 9 times 7 times so here and now
these are more difficult but here's
something from by the way the resource
called Persian online serial and so here
I've only listened to once because a
little bit difficult blah blah blah so
anyway there you have it just to let you
know that that the playlists are key and
that you you need to listen a lot at the
beginning and then you don't listen
quite as often is it possible
50 minutes of Pimsleur a day and 20
lessons and I talkie yes
20th the thing about I talk he is or any
kind of an online tutor situation you
know it's it's relatively expensive and
you're not gonna learn from your tutor
the tutor is one portion of it and I
think once twice a week is plenty
initiative because you have to put so
much effort into your listening and
reading and building up your okay okay
and then you can get more and more
benefit from your from your online
discussions with your tutor huh is it
possible to reach b1 in Chinese in three
months with hard work yes but that's
like full time I did that that's
definitely possible if I were to hire a
translator to do the mini stories in
when link accepted as a beta language
and what would you recommend be a fair
price for translation audio send me an
email on steve at link i think we have
been paying four dollars a lesson
translated and recorded but i don't know
for sure so please send me an e-mail we
can fall the the tiniest robot miss mama
spill koalas okay and i look forward I
gotta be in Louisville in Louisville
levite last week a make and would love
to see you there uh okay what should i
major in college if I love learning
languages well pick two languages two
languages that you really like and go
for no Steve I used to use the SRS
system very blue sort of my cards I was
over well it was overwhelming ever since
I found link I really used the SRS
system yeah I mean that's been my
experience you know I mean in in check
I've got sixty thousand words you know
even in Romanian twenty thousand Korean
forty thousand even in Arabic eight
thousand how am I gonna find the time to
review so many words while learning new
words I just don't see it but everyone
does what they like to do how do you
find literature that's relevant for you
I hope to find really exciting book in
target language and get some motivation
but there's so many mi skills aren't
perfect at all so for its well I would
need to know what the language is you
know for example for me literature is
difficult in learning Russian I went to
let you hear literature early because in
Russian there's so many excellent audio
books available for the literature of
the 19th century the literature of the
19th century is available free of charge
so I was able to import those ebooks
into link
I had separately listened to the
audiobook and I mean I can remember
hours and hours and hours of
cross-country skiing
you know listening to whatever cool
ganya at see dat which is one of my
favorite and so that was what I did you
got to look for it you know in the case
of polish I was able to find I went
there's a there's a website called audio
technica dot PL which has a lot of
audiobooks I found out look for the
corresponding audio book and ebook so I
can import the e-book in the link and
listen to the audiobook you got a Google
sometimes it's it's an easier sometimes
it's easy to begin by doing a book in
translation so I would go to if I don't
know how to say that in the in the
language or a target language I go to
google translate translate it
google it find the ebook audiobook
import the ebook in the link listen to
the audio ok I want to start learning
Russian in the summer or what and how do
you recommend me to start up you know
what my answer is gonna be go to link
there's lots of material in our library
certainly I would do the many stories
get yourself to a certain level and then
you go off in those areas that you're
interested in and Russian is one of the
languages for which there's lots of
resources online and you can import some
of those into link uh I got Alaska how
can I persuade my friend to use link
because he always sticks to the
antiquated methods from school it's kind
of an overage news link now it is
because it works you're on e the problem
is it's so difficult to persuade people
to use me you know any link member that
persuades a friend to join link gets 20%
like if that member becomes a paying
member then you get I think it's 20% for
recommending that person and so many
members do try to persuade their friends
to join link but it's difficult people
are stuck in their ways people and link
is a little bit overwhelming sometimes
we have so many functions a lot of
people find that overwhelming I find the
functions useful but a lot of people
find it confusing a lot of people want
to have chapter 1 chapter 2 chapter 3
it's the way they've been
sort of thought this is how languages
are learned so it's difficult it's
difficult but trying to persuade that's
all I can say Oh cheering yes okay the
move is experienced on this young
particular loan okay so what do how do
you stay motivated when we have bad
experiences and trying to use the
language you know when you are using the
language with the native speaker the
native speaker is not your teacher the
native speaker is not obligated to be
nice to you to be patient with you to
reply to you in the language you're
trying to use none of that so you
shouldn't have any expectations of how
the native speaker is going to react
when you use the language therefore I
focused mostly on building up my
competence in the language I derived
tremendous satisfaction from being able
to understand the language and when I go
to use it sometimes I do well sometimes
I don't do well sometimes the person is
encouraging sometimes the person is not
encouraging it doesn't matter to me I
continue to work on my enjoyment of the
language comprehension of the language
and in doing that I eventually get
better and better and as I get better I
have more and more positive experiences
with the language huh I have been
learning French for 123 days confidence
is my issue reading Harry Potter in
French probably the harder test can know
all the words but not be able to
understand assess yeah so it takes a
while for the brain to get used to it
sometimes you understand all the words
but the brain is not yet able to put it
together as a complete meaning partly
you're translating into your own
language all of this is just a matter of
learning is is a matter of getting used
to something it's it's a getting used to
process and so only more exposure and
more listening and more reading don't
just read because you get a different
sense of the meaning when you listen
because when you're reading your sub
vocalizing and you're trying to give it
a certain rhythm and stuff which
influences is the meaning but when you
hear it it's different so make sure your
combined listening and reading and keep
going okay I have to
the beginner and the language to listen
more read more you do both you listen
you don't understand you read you look
at the words you understand a bit better
you listen again you don't understand
that's why if I have been able to show
you how often I listen to them the big
the first mini stories in Persian or
Arabic is like 40 times okay so you need
both you need to get a sense of the
language the rhythm of the language but
then you need to look up the words to
make sense of it you need to do both I
want to ask you how do you maintain so
many languages and don't you mix some
words up yeah I do mix words up
I do mix words up Bob
and the languages do slip but they don't
slip that much if it's all there
somewhere and research shows that when
you forget something and then retrieve
it and relearn it you eventually learn
it better so it doesn't bother yes and
this is mark saeho mark hi everybody
mark run is linked any complaints you
have about link where are our t-shirts
why can't we have more Steve yes why
can't we have more items in our playlist
any other complaints and heat a boss our
guys we should get t-shirts yes or
something all right okay you can only
get something this is also marks room
while he's here so and we got a run here
what do we got here another that I
everything okay
try importing into link or try reading
cami unlink because the contracts open
late Monday yes absolutely
hi Steve any recommendations for books
about language acquisition stephen
krashen k-ras h en google find his
website lots of free stuff and he is the
best and he's got books that are not too
big like when i started on link i went
to book stores in London Stockholm
Vienna everywhere to find stuff about
language acquisition big thick books
it's mostly irrelevant
crashing and in a hundred pages tells
you all you need to know about language
acquisition k-ras h en stephen krashen
time to native-speaker how do you use
new vocabulary grammar while speaking I
want to join my conversation so if they
don't understand me I start speaking
bear-baiting yeah okay you know when I
speak I just focus on communicating but
if a word comes into my brain and I'm
entirely sure what it means I just use
it like go with it go for it take a
chance take us chance with your
structures make a mistake it doesn't
matter but the function is on on
communicating so by listening and I got
certain phrases running in my brain and
all of a sudden they popped into my
brain while I'm speaking I just used
them right or wrong I just use them I'm
learning French by the same time but
I've been learning French for four
months so do you think I can manage not
to confuse them because you learn Arabic
and farsi at the same time god yeah
French and Spanish of course are related
languages there's 20 30 % Arabic words
in Farsi and/or Persian and so there are
many times when I'm not sure if this is
an Arabic word or a Persian word
similarly when I speak Slavic languages
times I'm not sure if this is a
Ukrainian order a Russian word or a
Polish word so there's a certain element
of confusion but in the long run it's
not a problem they learning those two
languages in a sense helps it's
interesting to see two related languages
how they are different and when you
switch from the one to the other you're
gonna confuse them a bit but when you
then so that's for example why I'm doing
three and a half days of Persian three
and a half days of Arabic because if I
were gonna do the same language in the
same day I think I would get even more
computers but in my you know changeover
day I'm more likely to make mistakes so
for example I like to give myself one
day say if I switch from arabic to
persian on a you know it's starting on
persian on a wednesday i won't have my
online session till thursday so that i
at least have some chance to kinda wash
out the arabic and get the persian in
place but you do need to make mistakes
not a big deal I want to speak using the
new things I learned but when
communicative I start saying things I
usually say because I want to okay
yeah and so that's part of why you
shouldn't do too much talking online
because the amount of vocabulary you
will use in an online discussion with
the tutor at an early stage is very very
limited whereas when you are listening
and reading you're expanding your
vocabulary when you're speaking you're
using vocabulary or about and that's
gonna be a much more limited range yeah
I mean these deliberate attempts to
speak use newline new words every day I
mean I don't know if these are things
that you can actually maintain so I just
when I speak I speak I communicate we
talk about something I find myself
sometimes I surprised myself I use a new
word if not it's still very good
practice at speaking I often have to ask
the tutor how do you say this how to say
that I get all of that in my report it's
a nice thought me again stall you know I
think one can worry too much about these
things Cruz I spoke might rehearse
prepared lines the Chinese people my
tones were all flat Ron they said the
darkest tones are avast Chinese - okay
that's not true people we all like to
speak as well as we can and when a
foreigner non Chinese mini speaker
speaks with relatively good tones people
are much more appreciative than if they
speak with portals Tom's are something
that improves over time but it's
certainly not a conspiracy it's
important it's like accurate grammar
does learning a second language
increased first language skills
definitely every language you learn
increases your skills in all of the
languages you have a broader sense of
language of how to express things okay
yeah those you know what I just have son
so busy I can't as one day maybe we'll
have a conversational Skype that I'm I'm
gonna decline right now can you learn
tonight is it a learn one legs and
fluent and then the other two
intermediate level move on you do what
you want you can you do it you are the
main thing is to enjoy it I can't say
you know okay it's okay I would say that
this is plan re looking for an Iraqi
Arabic online tutor I would suspect that
if you went to high taki that you'll
find one otherwise you google Iraqi
Arabic online and you'll find one do you
sometimes think of a word like car in
ten different languages for the fun of
it no I can't say I've done do you know
that Arabic has 12 million and 300 words
on top okay thank you for hands Steve I
look for your next live sessions how do
we get the discount for recommending
someone to link how does that go I think
you know there's so much stuff I don't
know there again
go to the referrals tab under selves we
very much would like you to recommend
link and you do get a referral
compensation so under settings there is
a referrals now encourage you to
recommend link to your friend on the web
should I go in and share screen and show
that no it's okay anyway under okay
click on the profile image and under
that you'll find the referrals tab I do
have a French audio book for every part
so we'll keep listening to it all yeah
and absolutely like listening is key way
the biggest thing I find when people ask
me to review their profile it link
people don't listen enough you got on it
some tons for Italian I listened to it
promises palsy which even the Italians
don't listen don't read
I got an audiobook of it promises boss I
listen to her
Pinocchio in it out and I've listened to
I mean so my listening is the number one
thing that I do to learn languages and
then I follow up a meeting to understand
what was there daniel says hi mark
tell us please what's your favorite
language besides English English is not
my favorite language and I don't have a
favorite language
coverity Naruto no yama Godavari it's no
knee attack
Saban Katya Holly is it possible to
start with your novel after 6 knots
already
yes as you've been free of copyright so
I would bring it I would get the
audiobook and I would bring that et text
into link and learn all the words and
phrases on tymkovich sake on my hi Sam
espanol a DC Catania Setrakian Lawrence
a Vegas they mean to put you know this
includes to this money only Soviet yeah
no I mean Pedro said he had a
conversation in Spanish and she thought
he spoke well because he's just been
listening everybody absolutely like that
languages are similar in Spanish and
Portuguese not a problem even Romanian
you can learn it very quickly if you
know attack do you have a [ __ ] think
the days to learn certain languages no
only right now because I'm doing this
double-barrel persian/farsi thing at
least of Arabic Persian but is it fall
to reach a conversational level in
Chinese in three months brought during
college break I don't know
conversation Chinese longer takes longer
I'm speeding it up here because we got
to get going here I learned French
before anyone fairly wrong I'm currently
learning your Portuguese but it's
sticking as well as French are you we're
just gave me fell it's not sticking
yourself yeah now can I improve this
more more European Portuguese is kind of
difficult because it's I find it's more
difficult to understand than Brazilian
because they kind of tune or vowels sort
of but there there are tons of
Portuguese podcasts I listen to hundreds
of hours of radio Portugal
RTF I think it's called RTP oh yeah
google it radio Portugal podcast what
was it purse wallet
trust me Seco something like that it's a
whole series of interviews and what I
didn't have in those days with
transcripts but you can go to one of the
his automatic transcription sites like
vocal magmatic vocal Matic and you can
if you don't understand on transcriber
there's tons of Portuguese European
Portuguese podcasts out there and if you
can't find it send me an e-mail stiva
link below I want to know what you think
about learning English for me it is
still difficult because of one word has
many different meanings
I'm study s L 7 Cisco well yeah every
language has that
every night which has that there is no
secret you just have to listen and read
listen and read and you'll start to get
used to words and especially if you
learn words in context it will be
obvious to you because you'll know all
the surrounding words just what the
specific meaning of that word is in this
context do you think it's a good idea to
major in a language or is it bad idea
it's not a good or a bad idea the key is
not what you've said yet school the key
is what you do outside of the classroom
a very important area I just know where
you were at the beginning yeah you
should remind yourself how much you have
improved you have any pertinent thoughts
on breaking through that perhaps mental
barrier between intermediate level and a
truly huddle I don't know if it's a
mental barrier it may be but if you are
confident that you can listen to
literature audio books news really
understand the language then you'll have
the confidence to just use the language
and even if you struggle you'll
understand so clearly what people are
saying and you'll eventually improve
your ability to speak so it's more of
the same listening and reading have you
ever heard of Tim doner if you speak 20
languages 19 as only his speaks medicine
I've heard of him and I think he's
wonderful
I intend learn Chinese but I keep
hearing that it's the most difficult
language in the world from your
experience is that claim to not Chinese
is actually very easy it has a very
straightforward grammar it's easy to
accumulate vocabulary and two big
obstacles are the characters which are a
lot of work time and of course the tones
which you gradually get used to but it
is not difficult I find the grammar and
Slavic language is more difficult I am
finding Arabic in terms of the structure
of the language more difficult do you
think having ambitious goals like will
make you learn language faster because
you're shooting for the stars that has
not been my experience I think language
learning is not a sort of a sprint it's
a long distance run one that we enjoy
and I'm never in a hurry so we have
different approaches Japanese word order
makes longer sentences hard
yes and to some extent that's true in
German and that's another reason why you
need to do a lot of listening and
reading in order to get used to it and I
really have to run now so thank you
everyone and I'm on my way here bye for
now